i'm marie mcgrory a producer on national
geographic travel when my partner and i
went snorkeling on vacation we were not
expecting to meet a hug happy sea lion
so how did we get here and what's going
on with the sea lion
let's roll back the tape
la paz the capital of baja california
is a hub of aquatic adventures right in
the heart of what jack cousteau called
the aquarium of the world
a one-hour boat ride will take you to
esperitu santo a stunning group of
islands that are perhaps most famous for
their sea lion colony on lo sislotes
sea lions are naturally curious and
playful especially the juveniles
they explore with their mouths and can
often be seen nibbling on flippers
so what happened here
it seems like some of my partner's gear
caught the eye of this particular sea
lion
it grabbed onto his back so that it
could float its head above water and
play with his snorkel a little bit
this was such a cool moment and since my
partner remained calm we all really got
to enjoy it
i can't wait for my next trip back
[Music]
you